Speaker 1: So failed. Former President Donald
Trump is continuing to build up the story that
he's the victim. Everyone's treating him
so unfairly. The Aegean Carroll verdict was
unfair. The 2020 election results were unfair. The
impeachments were unfair to the Mueller probe. It
was all completely and totally unfair. Fox News
is treating him very unfairly. And I'm going to
show you a couple of examples of this from the
last 24 hours. And remember that the Trump family
may be the most thin skinned public folks that
we have seen in a very, very long time. Donald
Trump appeared yesterday on IK. So I always am
confused by what these shows are. I believe the
channel is real America's voice, which I still
don't know what that is. Is it a YouTube thing?
Does it stream? I don't know. The name of the
program is apparently just the news. No noise.
They interviewed Trump by phone. Trump plagued by
more audio issues echoing to high heaven and says
that he has been violated as badly as anyone.
There is no greater victim than Donald Trump.
Speaker 2: Certainly, I think I've been
violated as badly as anybody has ever
walked. There's never been any violation
like this. I've been violated beyond belief.
Speaker 1: And he's been more violated than
the woman he was found liable for violating
in a Bergdorf Goodman department store
in the nineties. Certainly, he's a bigger
victim than she is, according to him.
Speaker 2: As a political it's really
a political persecution. Everybody knows it and
there's never been anything like it. And frankly,
if I didn't fire James Comey, I probably because
that was a coup, that was a whole coup attempt.
Speaker 1: It was not a coup.
Speaker 2: And we beat it,
but we beat it was we beat some bad, bad
guys. Unfortunately, there haven't been
repercussions because people haven't taken it up.
Speaker 1: You need you know, that's exactly how
I feel about much of the Trump administration.
They tried a coup. There were some really bad
guys and unfortunately, there haven't been many
repercussions that that's exactly how I would
assess the Trump presidency. But he is continuing
on this. I'm a victim parade and then continuing
it over on Truth social.
Speaker 2: Truth Central.
Speaker 1: Where he said, quote, I don't know Jean
Carroll. I never met her or touched her except on
a celebrity line with her African-American husband
who she disgustingly called the ape. I wouldn't
want to know or touch her. I never abused her
or raped her or took her to a dressing room 25
years ago in a crowded department store where
the doors are locked. She has no idea when or
did anything else to her except deny her Capitol
fake made up story that she wrote in a book. It
Never Happened is a total scam. Unfair trial Trump
engage in caps lock for the last part of that and
then just continuing.
Speaker 2: Central.
Speaker 1: Page to the Carroll case is part of
the Democrats playbook to tarnish my name in
person. Much like the now fully debunked Russia
Russia Russia hoax, the 51 intelligence agents,
FBI, Twitter files and so much more. It is being
funded and tried by Democrat operatives, although
this was denied by them. And when they got caught
in the lie, the Clinton appointed judge would not
let us use it in trial time will prove him to
be highly partizan and very unfair. Where is the
dress she said she had? And then Trump continuing.
Speaker 2: Essentially.
Speaker 1: Shifting his ire towards Laura Ingraham
of Fox News, where he said, quote, Laura Ingraham
on Fox News just did a hit piece on me. There go
her ratings showing some polls which indicate that
Ron to sanctimonious may do better against Biden
than I would when actually polls show that I do
much better against Biden than Rob. The poll
you're looking at now wrong your which has me
doing far better against Crooked Joe was just put
out by Fox. I am sure unhappily I'm also leading
DeSantis by over 40 points in primary voting.
Watch Greg Kelly on Newsmax at 10 p.m.. Just
endless. Endless. Meanwhile, Barack Obama met with
a bunch of future entrepreneurs and folks working
for nonprofits discuss the importance of service
and also explored the coming A.I. trend. You know,
like you couldn't have a bigger contrast
between what these former presidents are
up to. And Trump is not stopping, but he is
still winning. The message continues to be
ABCDE. LFG That makes no sense that Trump
did, and yet MAGA continues to support him
and they will almost certainly make him the
Republican nominee unless something changes.